i think it's very important that
conservatives
assert their cultural and political
power because
the the field in which we're allowed to
play now in politics but also
economically
the the uh scope of things we're allowed
to say and allowed to do
is really shrinking and it's not just
being shrunk by big government
it's being shrunk by corporate america
it's being shrunk by the administrative
state it's being
shrunk by big tech it's being shrunk by
a lot of companies that are adopting
woke-ism
which brings me to a little bit of
personal news from this
show it actually pains me to relate this
but i feel i have to do it i feel i owe
it to the listeners
to relate this we have a lot of
advertisers on this show
some of them share our values many of
them don't share our values
and that's perfectly fine we don't we
don't discriminate
based on the views of some company and
they tend not to discriminate based on
our views
and we think if we we can have a good
partnership and if they've got a good
product we want to bring that good
product
to the people who listen to this show
harry's razors seems to have a big
issue with us now and a big issue
therefore with
our listeners we found this out over the
weekend
a twitter account that has two followers
that does not you know it doesn't seem
to be the most prominent or legitimate
real uh twitter account came out and it
complained at harry's to try to get
harry's to drop
this show harry's razors and said
harry's razors is sponsoring michael
knowles
who is spreading homophobic and
transphobic content you know and
how it did all the phobias and all the
isms and all that sort of thing
so harry's which has been a good partner
on this show and they make great razors
responded to this very small it would
seem
not totally legitimate twitter account
by saying thanks for bringing this up
we condemn the views in this video what
video is it we'll get to that in a
second
we condemn the views in this video which
are inexcusable and at odds with our
longtime support of the lgbtq plus
community we've ended our relationship
with this show
and are looking into our sponsorships to
prevent any values misalignment
going forward so i looked i said what
video are they talking about it's a
video
where i appeared on candace owens's show
at prageru
years ago and we were discussing the
transgender question
and in discussing that contradicted the
sort of politically correct view and
said oh you know maybe there's some
questions here right
i appeared on this show
a year i believe before harry's ever
started advertising on this show
the purpose of this show is to explore
the hot button political and cultural
issues and
offer a conservative perspective on that
a
perspective that is shared by tens and
tens of millions hundreds of millions
maybe of americans
but that is is not in line with the woke
politically correct fads and and uh
ideas that have really only cropped up
very recently
harry's knew that they knew all this
sort of stuff going in but when a
twitter account with two people
following it takes a hit
to try to prevent uh conservatives from
having advertisers and therefore to
prevent conservatives from
using good products using good razors
like hairy razors
they go in they buckle they spread this
then to their tens of thousands
of twitter followers and and they are
saying
we condemn the views in this video
they're saying we condemn the views
of conservative americans we think that
the views of conservative americans are
inexcusable
and at odds with our longtime views
advertisers cancel
on their campaigns with us sometimes and
then we get new advertisers sometimes
and that's totally fine there are plenty
of reasons why an advertiser
might cancel a campaign maybe we're just
not selling enough
enough of their product maybe they don't
like something that we
said maybe i don't know maybe the wind
blew in a certain way in the morning and
they just had to change
your heart that's all totally fine
advertisers have
every single right to do that it's just
a very different thing
when instead of just canceling their
campaigns with us
they start attacking just
us at daily wire but they start
attacking our audience and they say that
our audience's views are
condemnable inexcusable all sorts of
language
views which by the way no one's ever
been quiet about
and which it would seem that that
certain advertisers are just being
opportunistic
when some random twitter account says
something about it
that's a very different thing
advertisers more more than free to
cancel whenever they want but when you
start going after
us in a really vicious way when you
start going after our listeners and our
audience
then unfortunately for the advertisers
we need to speak up
there used to be a time in this country
not that long ago
where when you engaged in free
associations with people and i'm not
even just talking about economic
arrangements i'm talking about civil
associations the pta
the lions club where anywhere with your
neighbors in the neighborhood community
that you didn't have to have 100 perfect
ideological conformity on everything
and that's a better country that's the
country that we want to live in
but harry's i guess doesn't think we
ought to live in that country
harry's doesn't think that conservatives
deserve to have good razors
and uh you're you're free to make up
your mind with
what you'd like to do with that it's
kind of tough out there in the razor
game today
you've got you've got gillette uh
telling people
that you should teach your daughter to
shave her face you've got harry's now
saying that conservatives don't
have the right to to get good razors
this this
shrinking of the private sphere where
you can sort of have different views
with your neighbors and that's okay
this this ideological ideologization
of everything is that a word it'll be a
word now the the
i use that word because it's much more
specific but we sometimes call the
politicization of
everything now including the razors that
i have to be condemned
by my razor company because i hold
perfectly ordinary views that most
people have held for
most of history about you know the
nature of man and the nature of these
gender questions that have become very
fashionable now
that that is a really sad thing and so
we're we're
really disappointed in that because we
we've got such great relationships with
all of our advertisers the ones that
agree with us on lots of stuff the ones
that don't agree with us on lots of
stuff
we just try to be good partners just
like we would be good neighbors with
anybody around us
uh you know whether we have a hundred
percent conformity with them or zero
percent conformity with them
we try to be good neighbors and bring
people good products really uh really
unfortunate that harry's thinks that
conservatives don't deserve
good razors i hope you enjoyed that clip
from the michael knowles show
to check out the full episode hit the
link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you